there's a great non-profit in town
that's providing essential services
to at-risk babies and in connection with
that
is findlay toyota findlay automotive i
should say
and we're talking about uh tyler good to
have you with us
the lullaby connection how are you doing
i'm doing wonderful how are you
good tell us about lullaby connection
and what you guys are doing with them
well so first of all you know we do a
lot with a lot of different charities in
town so it's always kind of exciting to
find one that we haven't been involved
with before
and that's doing great stuff and so just
recently we learned about the lullaby
connection which is
they've actually been in operation here
for like 18 or 19 years
and they're just down the street from
our headquarters but
what we found out is that they serve a
real important need in town which is
that there's a lot of
parents brand new parents that have a
newborn child
but for whatever reason the pandemic or
just economic circumstances they don't
have the resources
to properly take care of their newborn
infant and that's where the lullaby
connection
gets involved and what they do is
you know their mission is to make sure
that every every newborn child has
has something to start their life with
something new something warm
something that's uh filled with love and
so they try to provide those types of
items
to these parents to give to their
newborn children such a great program
and i was i hadn't heard of them either
which is amazing
because they've been around for a couple
of decades yes
yeah so what they do is they provide uh
what they call a layout
package and i i had to look that term up
but what a layout
is is a set of clothing and accessories
for a newborn child and so the lullaby
connection provides these
and uh with blankets pajamas diapers and
other essential items for newborn babies
and they provided more than 50 000 of
these layouts over the last
50 or 20 years or so and so that's
really cool but
how we became aware of them was just
recently
we learned about their holiday need and
they normally serve about a hundred
families a year this year they're trying
to serve 600 and we learned that they
were way short of the items they needed
to help these families
in this very unusual year so we sent a
couple of our
our people chad and kristen from here at
our headquarters
and sent them to the store and we
delivered a whole
vehicle full of toys and items to help
them
and so they're meeting the needs of
those 600 families
for the holidays which is something that
makes us feel good based on everything
that's going on right now
well you guys do so much for so many
non-profits and so many people in this
community and we thank you for it
um the viewers people watching right now
if they want to help some of these
children they can help as well right
yeah so obviously financial support is
something that they could always use but
they also accept donations of new toys
and
clothes for infants uh even baby books
and that sort of thing and so you can
always
uh provide that sort of thing the best
way to get more information is go to
lullabyconnection.org learn about what
they do
how you can help and get involved and we
really encourage it if you're going to
support something here at the holidays
this year
we'd love to have you support the
lullaby connection it is a great cause
tyler at
as always you done good thanks so much
great to see you thank you so much
and we do want to thank findlay
automotive for being one of our
community
pride partners las vegas now we'll be
right back